hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are in my kitchen and we are
making a freaking pumpkin pie and I'm so
excited because I love pumpkin pie and
I've never made one before so I'm not
really sure how this is gonna go I've
done a lot of google research about
pumpkin pies but I think what I'm gonna
do is I'm just gonna follow the recipe
on the back of this can it says it's a
famous pumpkin pie it makes ten servings
so I've got all of my ingredients ready
we're gonna make this in the blender
obviously there's also a problem because
I realized I don't have ground ginger I
don't have ground cloves but what I do
have is an abundance of pumpkin spice
spice and I don't know what's in here
but it smells good so I'm basically just
gonna dump a bunch of this in there and
across my fingers and hope for the best
what I do have is nutmeg and cinnamon
which I kind of have a feeling that this
is all in here anyway so I don't know
who knows Happy Thanksgiving
cinnamon ginger cloves in small bowl see
I can't do that because I'm making this
in the blender so I need to put the
liquid ingredients in first so what
we're gonna do we're gonna put the
evaporated milk in first I hope this is
evaporated Belka yep evaporated milk is
fresh nutritious milk from which half
the water has been removed come on No so
sugar who put you in there two large
eggs one up to one test ground cinnamon
I was surprised it tisp is actually a
lot more than I go that's definitely
more than a tisk pumpkin spice
everything nice I know but a cinnamon if
you will that's super spicy enough but
not least we need a pumpkin or using
Libby's said it was famous
maybe libby should make something for
Thanksgiving that would be good I may
have a few new subscribers who might be
a little confused about my channel are
you a baking channel or you a tech
channel why are you dressed as a lobster
these are questions that I'm unable to
answer for you I am me I'm also confused
the pumpkin is actually really good for
dogs when they have diary
pumpkin pie pumpkin pie I mean that's
that's really it well I guess we'll set
this aside while we prepare our crust
now we're gonna make this very special
because I am making a pumpkin poo pie
where does the poo come into play and I
got this beautiful pie pan off of Amazon
it's beautiful it's like super official
I've never had a pie pan before why
would I have one because I don't bake
pies but today I'm making some pie I've
got this it's a it's called macula Lee
honestly delicious pie crust No let's
see how it works look at this oh this is
great
I just have to roll it out I like what
cancel okay anyway I hold myself back
together all right here's our dough
that's it that's that's it like I just
literally rolled this out oh it's very
cold oh you're supposed to just roll out
is it frozen no it's just refrigerated
it says 20 room temperature for 25 to 30
minutes 60 minutes of frozen doughnut
crack if you cold
be sure to let this set for a required
time before unrolling don't don't can I
put on the microwave
this sauce
[Music]
don't oh God melting every bad idea
I'm so sad I guess what I don't care get
in there we're gonna mold this back
together and we're gonna make this pie
look at beautiful as can be pinch it
like no one's gonna see the bottom of
this pie I mean honestly it to be
totally honest with you if anyone eats
this they're probably gonna die so let's
be real
look at this it's looking perfectly fine
push this down at the bottom so I'm
gonna probably open one of these other
ones so upset so I'm gonna put this in
the microwave again no okay Nathan the
shape pieces had a very rapid no like
what this may be like beat like warm
itself up inside here so I can I'm gonna
pour in the mixture now this is very
liquidy like this pumpkin pie supposed
to be like a pumpkin spice freakin latte
or what's up this looks very suspect
Alexa it's pumpkin pie supposed to be
watery mm-hmm I don't know that see I
don't either
so the reason this is gonna be a pumpkin
poo pie is I'm going to be using
Rosanna's little poo emoji cutout here
oh this is starting to glisten anyway
you guys know how on pumpkin pie is they
always have those little like
decorations on them like festive little
leaves well we're gonna have a cutout
poop on it and I'm gonna bake it a
little poop separately and then I'm
gonna put the poop on top of it and
really this is all theoretical
I just I'm obviously at this point I
don't even know if this is gonna even
cook like this looks like trash it looks
like I went to Starbucks took a pumpkin
spice latte and dumped it inside of here
questionable Wow
[Music]
we've got a problem this is so hot it's
boiling I can't use this Oh No
John Donne Tom this is clearly not gonna
be edible I've ruined Thanksgiving do
you guys remember I think it was last
year at Thanksgiving and my one project
that I was supposed to make was pumpkin
bread that's what I didn't do make the
pumpkin bread properly all right we've
got one last try this one's too hot this
one's too cold it still feels a little
cold you can do it
Jenna can you bring me a hairdryer
I can't unroll this last little bit
because I know it's gonna be too cold so
I think a hairdryer may solve the
problem magenta sees what I'm using this
far I'm gonna set everything off to the
side
a little bit of a crack
it's okay
so I'll be heating it up because I
didn't saw and then the rest of them
cracked you'll see in the video later so
to make it the pumpkin poo emoji we're
gonna use this little pumpkin cutouts
cut this out just like so and we're
gonna bake that separate now I mean a to
warm hey Jen can you come here we need
to transfer this on to the pumpkin pie
without breaking it two months yes that
stink
it's disgusting wait I think this is
gonna work jam it back in then what
happened there oh okay
wait let's put it back together oh you
know what okay because we're gonna do
we're going did it work did you put this
here you're gonna add some of these
little holes here and I'm gonna cut this
rest of this off we pinch this all
together so like honestly I think that
this will just sort of like merge back
together and everything will be fine
I've already ruined Thanksgiving you
remember oh yes I've already told them
try to make a vegan pumpkin from me this
is like so sure I'll just put it back in
the oven or this is just like an
impossible I think it's the top so the
directions that says let's do a couple
of different things 15 to 20 minutes
you're supposed to cover the outer crust
which I have a little thing for that so
this protects the edges like why do I
even care I mean at this point this is
an absolute mess so this covers the
outer edges here so they don't get too
crisp and
yeah I'm not sure I would just say don't
do anything that I'm doing in this video
340 350 400 okay well I'm gonna let that
preheat then put this thing in the oven
and I will see you guys shortly a lot of
things have happened first of all I
think the only successful thing that has
happened is this tiny little poo that I
cut out of the original dough I baked
this for about 15 to 20 minutes there's
a lot of things that went on because it
was like oh okay so at 15 minutes you
have to turn the temperature down to 350
and then 20 minutes remove the little
thing around the crust and then do
something else it was like this is a lot
of work and the whole time I'm watching
this freaking pie and it is jiggling
like jello like my body and slow motion
so we're gonna take it out I don't know
what to expect I'm slightly nervous and
I'm actually a little upset because I
really did try moderately hard to make
this work
Wow it is crisping up a freaking storm I
think I probably should have taken it
out like 20 minutes ago
it's bubbling I should probably close
the oven okay do you want to get in here
and take a look yeah like it looks like
do I have to let it cool before I can
cut it
are you a pumpkin pie expert that's not
like pumpkin - shut up what do you think
it is encrusted on top like all the hope
you guys I've ever had were like just
pump look at those
that's our poo looks what did I mess it
up just wash this is so hot oh there we
go that's nice yeah careful now what do
I do I'm so I'm so confused like oh my
gosh but I want to eat it now so I
probably have to let this cool off and
oh my gosh guys put whipped cream on it
melt mm-hmm okay well I guess I'll let
this cool off and then I'll see you guys
in a little bit like what I look so bad
I still never seen a pumpkin pie like
that you've never helped occupy overtop
of like apple pie oh no you're right I
don't
did you make apple pie huh
I completely messed this up from the
beginning and I was wondering what the
plan was I've never seen it done that
I've never even maybe you're onto
something maybe I'm an idiot or movie
this your version like I did not even
think about it I've never seen a pumpkin
pie with freaking crust on the top of it
you're right it's apple pie oh my gosh
OOP goodbye
pumpkin poop I can buy a pumpkin
oh man okay well I'll let this cool off
and then we can try it we've got the pie
ready and cooled god this thing's so
stupid I still can't believe that I put
crust on the top of it like in my mind
because there was two crusts in the box
that was like well of course I put crust
on top of the pie of course that oh it
smells good Wow oh wow
this is this is like soup
this did not firm up the way that it
should Oh at all oh my gosh
like I don't want to try this but I have
to
so it's actually not bad but this
consistency I do not think is correct
and all this extra flaky goodness let's
try this crust oh god that is burnt that
is burnt that is not good look at this
that is super crusty super crisp Jen I
would offer you some of this but I would
actually recommend you don't eat it
I burnt it go get your trash spoon you
might as well just take a scoop from the
middle it's up alright yeah it's not bad
it's just like it's like pudding
well pumpkin pie usually a little softer
yeah but this is like soon is it still
oh look at this this looks like garbage
yeah just take a bite at that
well guys thanks for watching if you
don't see me again it's because it's
because I died from making a pumpkin pie
well thank you guys so much for watching
Happy Thanksgiving I love you guys let
me know what you would like to see me
make in the future in the comments below
if you haven't already subscribed to my
channel a do so by clicking subscribe
and make sure guys like the video if you
somewhat enjoying it if you didn't like
it just click like anyway to make me
feel better about how much time I'd
spent making this pumpkin pie and it's
not good what did I do wrong
if you guys have any recipes for me
please please let me know I did so many
things wrong so many things but now I
know over the next time my next pie will
be immaculate it will be beautiful I
think if I recall I can't open that
there's some things in there I think
that the dough that I used was called
immaculate dough do you remember was it
I think it was so my next pie will be
immaculate this was a massacre I'll see
you guys later bye oh man I tried some
hard on like I'm so sorry I actually
really tried
okay and seen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]